they don't want us to see him as the
idea right because like they leave Clues
like crop circles they're flirting no
farmers are dumbest they don't even know
how to read it's how they're going to
read they're probably gonna read a crop
circle right and then you agree with
this right I absolutely agree yeah
do you guys remember when World War
Three almost happened but then aliens
stopped it yeah
where were you when that happened really
I was here what happened you don't you
don't remember that no where were you
where were you Joe probably swimming
okay
so yeah there was
um an incident
um where Russian fighter jets once fired
at possible extraterrestrial life forms
after a pair of UFOs nearly caused World
War Three to break out according to
sworn testimony shared to Congress
testimony was given by a guy named
George Knapp you heard of George map
before
you've probably seen him before if
you're if you follow the UFO field he is
a Las Vegas based journalist who broke
the Bob Lazar store oh okay okay which
has been kind of crazy recently because
we've heard a lot of things that babazar
was saying like 30 years ago actually or
more longer
kind of regurgitated in the Congress by
this guy named David grush who's a UFO
whistleblower
and you guys I'm sure you guys followed
that intensely right yeah yeah
whistleblow dude that recently had his
like thing go public yes
that guy what do you think of that one
Ryan I don't think he's a whistlebler
because he's he was permitted to speak
on behalf of it he was permitted to
speak after filing a report
um a whistleblowers report that's what
made him be allowed to speak but he
still has to keep it all kind of under
wrapped so he can't quite say everything
it's not like what's his name like
Snowden when he blew whistle they were
[__] coming after him yeah they were
mad at him but then he's like allowed to
speak this guy well because he just
don't he did a data dump Snowden he just
dumped everything but this guy can't do
that well he wants to do it on the law
or he'll go to jail uh you could be a
whistleblower but you can't spread
classified information so he can talk
around certainly oh that's different
yeah so he's like a
little tiny little tiny yeah he's not a
whistle kazoo kid yeah a permitted
whistleblower he's more like a
mouth breather
he doesn't even have a whistle oh in
this testimony right Mr Knapp said that
Russians had carried out what was
probably the largest UFO investigation
in history spending over a decade and he
said that he spoke personally to a
Russian military official who said that
there had been no less than 45 different
incidents where Russian fighter jets had
clashed with UFOs with Russian jets
crashing in three of those incidents
resulting in the deaths of two pilots
during these incidents
um one incident that really raised alarm
Bells though was at a Russian ICBM base
in Ukraine International or energy
UFOs somehow took control of the launch
system they appeared over a base right
so you just see the base UFOs appeared
they're like moving at all different
angles and and Maneuvers that make no
sense right yeah flying backwards and
[__] exactly then they take they're
going upside down and [__] yeah changing
directions midair that's wild so then
they take control of the launch system
the missiles at the time were aimed at
the U.S they were suddenly fired up like
ready to go right launch control codes
get completely entered and the base
couldn't have stopped what was about to
happen and then all of a sudden just as
suddenly as they showed up the UFOs
disappeared in the launch control system
completely shut down it just shut down
shut down they disarmed it they powered
it up and they turned it off and they're
saying that they're not able to turn it
down something else turned it down for
us something else something something
else turned it on and turned it off wow
it wasn't them that's pretty great that
was almost going to be World War III
because obviously we have what we call
deterrence right nuclear deterrence
right which is like hey if you bomb us
guess what we're gonna buy me back and
then
yeah have you heard that theory that
like um because all these uh UFOs are
like appearing near like all of those
things called like nuclear reactions
there's those yeah nuclear facilities
yeah that like they're drawn to that
energy and uh maybe there's something
about that that they're coming like oh
[__] we can feel there's this crazy ass
energy coming from I heard that it was
like they're they're like checking up on
our progress and they're like oh [__]
these guys are no longer in the Iron Age
yeah it's like Star Treks they're like
oh oh one of my favorite points that
some people make is like How Could An
Interstellar craft that can travel light
years to get here have trouble on Earth
and crash
oh [__] it's like that Indian doctor who
crashed his Tesla when his wife was
backing up or you know what probably
they probably dude they probably have
the dash light on and that's you know
you can't see [__] yeah yeah maybe they
were just drunk oh that could be I like
cars functioning fine they're just the
driver's fault they're drunks you got a
little cockier I like the idea that that
they're not from other planets they just
exist at an altitude so [__] high
that it's like in the ionosphere like
all these things in here yeah they just
they just [__] like how you [__]
lives at the bottom of the ocean that
you never saw oh yeah I've never heard
that theory before yeah it's pretty cool
dude there's so much on this topic
though like I was doing manic you were
doing a podcast about this and these
people like people think that first of
all that they come here to show us that
they are in charge so like they power up
our dominance thing yeah dominance move
ooh there are also people who think that
they're basically saying like you know
protect the Earth which is the store
like the the um the Hollywood
um we always see that portrayed in
movies like that Keanu Reeves movie
where he's he's like he's a knowing
everybody chill is that the name of the
movie Constantine no it was like it was
like a remake of an old movie but it's
like yeah it's him oh Bogus Journey To
Earth and he's gonna destroy it but then
realize that there's good people he
likes these trees or some [__] yeah he's
like wow A Scanner Darkly beautiful I
changed my mind yeah just because people
suck doesn't mean trees suck maybe it's
not that kind of [__] but yeah those are
and then there's also the theory too
that they signed an agreement already
with us which is kind of what Mr grush
was kind of talking around with our
leaders with our leaders the Bilderberg
Group and there's been a an agreement in
place with them and we don't exactly
know what what's going on
technology transfer so they gave us some
tax if they had an agreement I'd feel
way better about it right because then
they had met they have terms they're
like aliens can you so can you teach us
how to book cameras in the phone and
they're like we got you and then so
every year they give us a new fun thing
we can do dude what do you think what do
you think we give them
people yeah people you think we give
them like some only fans chicks I think
Bart said yeah booties
we want the booty I think it's funny
that like if aliens wanted to
communicate there's so many ways
throughout time they could have done and
it's so [__] easy like just get on
channel 11. yeah just the way the Max
Headroom [__] guy did it like just go
on the radio which we have waves for
that or go [__] streaking in a soccer
field yeah I'm here
he gets tackled like go on the I don't
know internet yeah what's the point of
being so invisible oh we can't let him
see us it's like why if you're like
powerful like why like
you're so naked they don't want us to
see him is the idea right because like
they leave Clues like crop circles and
[__] they're flirting no farmers are
dumb as [__] they don't even know how to
read that's how they're going to read
They're Not Gonna read a crop circle
right and then you agree with this right
I absolutely agree yeah and so so then
they're like why would we want to show
you who we are we go hide in the oceans
and we hide in the moon and yep that's
cool that's tight that's a way cooler
hiding places really cool and if you've
been paying attention like the Navy's
been saying they've been seeing hella
sightings over the ocean especially off
the coast of San Diego which is where
that cat who talked to Joe Rogan you
just talked to Congress said that he saw
the Tic Tac uh UFO oh the guy that's
being interviewed yes the former um Navy
pirate pilot yeah yeah that [__] was
crazy have you heard a Battle of Los
Angeles yes they thought that Amer uh
Japan was invading La when they saw up
into the skies they saw all these flying
things and then like and then they
realized they were flying saucers
battling each other there was so there
was like um spotlights back then right
because they were looking for for planes
from potentially Japan right because
Pearl Harbor had been hit so they had
spotlights and they were they were
pointing at a UFO during like World War
II and then there was like huge um
batteries of anti-aircraft [__] firing
in the night you can still find bullets
like in LA from that night because they
fired so many rounds whoa the next day
they reported they were firing at
something they don't know what the [__]
it was that's [__] crazy I've heard
people try to explain the Tic Tac
movements they try to explain it with
like oh those are just Chinese drones
I've heard people say that but the TIC
tac's been around before China had any
technology yeah that's [__] it's a
stupid well why wouldn't China I mean my
whole thing about this is like why
doesn't China or Russia if it's them
just [__] take over everything yeah
like you can do whatever you want right
yeah if you had that Tech yeah just take
it all over you're good right I think
you're gonna have a problem in Ukraine
yeah if you guys had Tic Tac drones yeah
yeah it always just seems a little too
perfect it just if you've been through
the Jesus era of your life it's hard to
just see that everything's faith-based
and it's like okay well you have to
believe in them for them to exist but my
Jesus air is my favorite era one of the
theories one of the theories is that uh
you know to in order to get a One World
Government you need people all over the
world to unite and then they're so
saying like a lot of the uh the powers
that be you want to keep and stay in
power so they're going to unite the
world through uh that's interesting
that's cool that's what blue beam was
about it's like fake an alien attack to
unite the world like to whatever cause
we want and none of us
seen one but we just gotta trust it I've
seen one I saw a UFO I talk about all
the time yeah so you've over Flagstaff
Arizona when I was moving here in 1996
never forget it I see a light in the sky
and it was just hanging out there
forever and I thought it was like a
[__] star it was so bright
and my whole family saw it with me and
then as we get closer and closer like we
get we're getting like a tour we're
going to be underneath it it's so much
higher than any light could be like it
was it was bright as a streetlight
though and then all of a sudden and it
was hanging up there for like 15 minutes
and then all of a sudden out of nowhere
a cloud appears around it and it gets
sucked inside of itself and completely
disappears there's no Vapor or anything
completely this is at night this is
during the day
wow a cloud yeah and there was not a
cloud in the sky it was just this it was
a ninja with a smoke bomb a sky ninja
Sky ninja oh they're around they're
around so out of all the other stuff
that you've researched and you heard of
have has is there any other accounts of
something similar yeah did someone see
the same thing what if it's a military
plane that's so technologically advanced
that it would yeah Why didn't it move
that's my thing it wasn't even moving it
was just staying there it was just
staying there and some people have been
like well maybe it was a it was a flare
but if it was a flare wouldn't there be
some kind of vapor before and also
remnants of of the flare too but yeah
there was no train I know what if it
looks like and there was no Trail or
tail to the flare at all zero someone
said that too what if these are all just
time machines is that so is that so
weird don't be sick am I crazy I like
the internet dimensional aspect of it
too that like one of the theories so
that's a good one what's the other
what's that there that actually
resonates more with me so one of the
beliefs about aliens is
um future humans they lost the ability
to procreate and breed because they saw
that you know we're seeing this now with
with IVF and just like even surrogates
and now we're having test tube babies
right yeah so they're like the
inconvenience of giving birth partnering
up all that stuff they're like it's more
efficient if we just like create humans
yeah and then we biologically engineered
ourselves to look like great aliens wow
like so like for Interstellar travel for
like all these things so they're like
when gray aliens are coming now they're
just harvesting DNA that they need in
order to create more humans that's a
cool Theory well there's also an idea so
you remember you were saying about the
crashes like why are these why are these
guys so smart but they keep crashing so
there's another theory too they're Asian
yeah they're all Asian
no there's another theory yeah
Reddit post
there's a Reddit post about a guy who
says he works at like a one of these
military bases but they do biologics
there and he says that they they had
these beings like the bodies of these
beings on site and that they're
basically like avatars like they're
biologically created so that they can
um project like through space through
time and space and then the aliens don't
have to they can just chill at home and
[__] eat Doritos or whatever and then
the biologic so that's like their Avatar
or just avatars look spacesuits oh [__]
they don't even have to be in the suit
they just sending these biologics so
that's their VR yes and I did by the way
I did a whole hour podcast on this if
you're interested in that topic I
[__] crushed it on that explanation
and it makes more sense yeah so check it
out and [__] they don't tell you because
we don't have time but I'm telling you
man it's a fascinating Topic in this
entire Reddit post was so detailed but
I'm also like a not smart person so
maybe it wasn't that detail but it was
so detailed I was like it was compelling
this is compelling as well